right now we covered Thomas yesterday
and I sort of just talked at you for a
long time so well done on on on keeping
away through but let's see if we can on
let's see if we can revise it what did
we cover before we um got to this idea
of an integral where we start what was
the problem
so I started we start with J okay
mathematically what we started with it
was the area under a curve okay because
because of the okay so we move from area
under curve right through this guy this
german guy named riemann okay his clever
idea of breaking an area up breaking
this area up into an infinite series of
infinitesimally thin rectangles and then
adding them up and using limits to
actually make it exact and not just an
approximation okay so that was the basic
idea now think where we left off I gave
you an example but sort of like that we
concluded is that if we were to define
and this is um an important thing I want
you get down if we were to define this
area right underneath in this case
but not just any area underneath we want
it between set and bounds we pulled them
the upper and lower bounds right lower
cause you're stuck here so between these
two vertical lines x equals a and x
equals B that's what they really are
right Riemann defined that fake as this
infinite Sun right
Sigma was already taken okay oh there's
X okay and then at the very end of the
lesson we're dealing with that example
question I'm just a little bit of extra
notation which is to say look what this
becomes that this process of integrating
is really finding the premium function
right so you take that and you evaluate
it at those bounds and you take the
difference okay so taking the difference
with me and this okay so make sense so
what you've got here let me circle this
all of these things are really the
reason why I put it all across is
because they're all equal ways of saying
excuse me the same thing now probably
the most important out of all of these
expressions is this one okay no it
sounds what I'm gonna give it a name I'm
gonna try the time I'm the name for this
particular one even they're all
equivalent
there's a definite integral okay hence
the honey and what does that mean well
we already introduced the idea integral
why is it called an integral it's
because you're integrating combining all
of these little rectangles okay but it's
called a definite integral because it's
defined on certain boundaries okay it's
an area in a particular place it's a
specific area okay it's an actual thing
that I can point to right however
earlier on we were looking
primitive functions on their own right
this whole f-prime capital deathly right
we looked at the idea of just going
through this process of integrating with
that specific balance without an actual
area in mind okay just going through the
algebraic process okay
so if you go through that process you
don't have boundaries you don't define
it in a certain place rather than
calling it an undefined integral we call
it an indefinite integral so if we go
through the process and don't put an A
to B we don't put upper and lower
breaths again okay this thing is called
okay now since it's not attached to a
specific set of balance right this part
here kind of short-circuits
alright cuz it's not it's not you're not
evaluating it at two different places
and then taking a difference because
there are no places to evaluate it out
okay now no keeping that idea in your
head if I take away these bounds right
I'm evaluating anymore but I'm still
going to go through the process of
getting to the primitive function okay
so this is one we looked at where we
looked at anti-differentiation so this
is going to be capital F but remember
the Y was the reason why I could ignore
the plus C that constant that came up
right the read is gonna cancelled out
right this process here the subtraction
meant the constants here and the
constants there so cancels out now since
I'm not doing a subtraction here right I
can't just ignore the cluster it has to
come back okay
so a definite integral is an area right
in fact it's actually a number like it's
in ten units or or 50 units of square
right definite integral's a number the
indefinite integral is a function right
it's a function yeah it's off it's not
just a function it's a function with the
constant okay now as I've taught this
before people got really confused when
they say is two different clients
integrals and ones going to closer and
what does it like what's up with that
we shouldn't be that confused though
because we're used to this idea of two
different kinds of integrals from
derivatives we think about it this way
it's just that we haven't given it the
same kind of language okay write this
down as an example let's consider a nice
simple function like say X square now if
we were to differentiate that right what
would you get you get f - that's how we
normally call that right
and that's GX now you can call the
derivative we also call it the gradient
function right why do we call the
gradient function ah good if you sub in
a value right for instance let's put in
x equals 3 okay you'll get out a number
at the end right and this is an actual
gradient at a specific place right this
is the great year at x equals 3 okay so
it's the same kind of idea right if I
want to give it the same kind of
language that we use to describe
integrals right I suppose you could call
this definitely derivative because the
dreamin and it's defined at a certain
place namely x equals 3 okay in the same
way I guess this is kind of like an
indefinite it's like well it'll give you
the gradient wherever you want it okay
but you haven't told me where you want
it okay
in the same way that the indefinite
integral would give you the area if you
gave it boundaries so we don't use this
language because
actually I don't know why we don't use
it the same consistent across birth if I
could guess I think it's because
different groups of people different
groups of people came up with these two
different ideas to solve different
problems right so maybe but if you
wanted to carry so I think this if this
is helpful if you want to carry the
gradient function gradient language over
two integrals right you would call this
you call that just an area that's
already called that right and I suppose
the parallel would be this is an area
function right
just like the derivative is a gradient
function okay it's a function what area
is okay so this idea of an indefinite
integral what it really does is it kind
of formalizes or solidifies the idea you
can do integration and have it as a
separate thing from area right because
you can think about it as a process
which is just algebra which is what we
did the end of last term right I said
look you guys know how to go from this
to that life and differentiate so just
go in reverse
okay and we didn't introduce ed to your
area at all okay so therefore what I
want to try and help you see the
parallel is that we can use this sum you
don't get it s and the DX right as an
operator just like D on DX right so this
what we call the differential operator
okay it means well how do you read it
what does it actually tell you to do -
if I put something in front like F what
is it what is it till you do that
like okay tells you to differentiate
find the derivative but it tells you
more than that doesn't it because it
told you something different to say this
now it actually didn't tell you what the
function is in terms of but tells you
what to do with it right
so if I have when we looked at that our
X doesn't rates of change that you
receive different kinds of D's down the
bottom your D something else da DT
whatever okay so he's differentiate with
respect to a particular variable and you
pick it out and you can differentiate
with respect to other variables too
right so therefore you know just like
this was a differential operator this is
we call the integral operator right
so it means integrate with respect to X
ok
so I'm trying to develop this idea that
these are inverse operators of each
other okay now let me prove it to you
so it's this thing on its own it doesn't
mean anything
right it's like do this to something
it's a it's a verb it needs an object
operators differential operator because
of different chance and the integral
operator because it integrates alright
now before I prove this inverse
relationship and hope she how it works
okay let me just do a quick quiz do
something like this what's that equal to
simple question
x squared on two plus the constant cuz
indefinite right okay how about this 3x
procedure problems right okay how about
this lot C so so there's a there's a one
hiding in there isn't there okay it's
not a zero it's not a zero because
otherwise there would be there would be
0 times the introduction zero right so
the fact that it is a DX sitting there
means that one is implied so therefore
if you take the primitive one it is X
plus your constant for course now just
keep that in your head for a second now
let me let me prove this relationship to
you by thinking off two different
functions one being the derivative now
keep in mind right that the X in
brackets right we don't actually need
that day it's just a reminder of the
fact that capital F and F are not
numbers what are they
it functions right but often we just
leave off the X for instance when I
write this okay and then I write this
you know that Y is not just a number you
know that Y is actually a function of X
okay but we think off because you know
we already know that right so in the
same way I'm just going to leave off the
X for a second okay I haven't changed
anything I'm just rewriting it short
okay now what that tells you is this
okay which looks very similar to this
kind of thing here would be used to okay
it's just that it's a capital F instead
of a wide right now see this is going
I'm trying to show the relationship
between the only X this operator in this
one okay so I need to get from division
to multiplication so I'm going to take
out DX and I'm gonna kick it over here
is everyone okay so far I haven't done
anything too dramatic
right okay now I'm gonna integrate both
sides you can differentiate both sides
you can square both sides and do
anything you like
so if I just slap be integral operator
on the fun
what does this mean nothing you know
exactly what it means right because when
you integrate just a D whatever right
you just get back whatever the D was
right integrating with respect to X just
gives you an X right so if I integrate
with respect to capital F what should
you expect here this is just capital F
right and just for the sake of clarity
I'm gonna slap the the X's back on so
you can see it's a function right plus
my constant and over here I'm just going
to leave that as it is because this is
what I wanted to show okay I wanted to
show the relationship between the two
they're opposites to each other